what does the Norwegian Nobel Committee
want to achieve by awarding the prize to
the Colombian President only we want to
honor him and make it tribute to the
very important work he has been doing he
initiated the peace process he has been
very active and very clear that he
wanted the process to move on towards a
peace agreement and he very quickly
after the referendum results came out
and said that he invited to a broad
national dialogue to go on some people
will perhaps a that it is ignoring the
will of the people when you give them
when you're awarded the price just to
the president no not at all I I do not
agree with this in the announcement text
you will see very clearly that this is
also a tribute to the Colombian people
who have kept up there hope for justice
and for peace and reconciliation it is a
tribute to all the parties national and
international who have participated in
this and last but not least to the
representatives of the weaklings who
have been participating quite actively
in the process would it have been easier
to to give a price to the president and
the leaders of the FARC irelia if
they're a friend of wood has shown there
yes that would be pure speculation for
me to answer this it's a hypothetical
question and I don't give you an answer
that what are the criteria in the ALF in
alfred nobel's will has been most
relevant in this decision when you have
given the price on boarding the price to
the president well all the criteria in
fact have been relevant and
we underline that it has made the
foundation for a reduction or to do away
with the weapons we have also seen a
cease fire and it is important to see
that this is in a way a movement towards
a reconciliation we are saying to put it
quite correctly that the groundwork much
of the groundwork has been laid for the
verifiable disarmament of the gorilla
and an historic process of national
fraternity and reconciliation spend this
endeavor we feel is totally within the
criteria will and also the spirit what
have been what has been most difficult
during the process ending up in today's
decision well it's always a long and
difficult but very interesting process
and it takes many many months we follow
some candidates very closely this has
not been a more difficult year than
other years but we do everything we can
to evaluate and assess the candidates
with think are worthy of the price this
is a controversial decision that's not
for me to say I think we will hear from
the comments whether it's controversial
or not and then I turned to the
secretary of the committee is this a
controversial price we hope not the
committee has stressed very clearly that
they hope this will on the country help
to unite the Colombian people
to join forces to reach a final broadly
acceptable agreement or will you
describe the decision made by the
committee it's not my role to describe
or comment upon the decision I think
it's a very very important price I just
had a chance to talk with President
Santos himself on the phone and he was
overwhelmed and he said immediately that
this is very very very important for my
country and for the continuing peace
process